bonsoir patrick bruno solo yvan le
bolloc'h liane foly patrick dils à
l'heure patrick dils si vous avez été
condamné à la prison à perpétuité pour
avoir avoué le meurtre de deux petits
garçons alexandre et cyril c'était en
1986 à montigny les metz et quinze ans
après lors de votre troisième procès
après 15 ans de prison
les jurés vous emportant reconnu
innocent et vous ont acquitté vous
raconter cette tragédie qui vous a coûté
votre jeunesse
dans un livre intitulé je voulais juste
rentrer chez moi
publié chez michel lafon paul ferrère
[Musique]
alors je voulais juste rentrer chez moi
le titre du livre amène directement à ce
que vous dites
lorsque vous avez été arrêté pour
expliquer vaut aveu vous avouer le
double meurtre des enfants pour que
l'inspecteur en fait tout simplement
vous laisse rentrer chez vous après
trois jours et deux nuits de garde à vue
pour retrouver votre votre papa et votre
maman ouaip tout à fait si vous voulez
ça s'est passé de la manière suivante
lorsque j'ai été arrêté le 28 avril 1987
pour la troisième fois la forme était
donc décisive
gr j'ai été entendu pendant de
nombreuses heures et j'ai toujours dit
la vérité et dans la soirée ma mère a
téléphoné donc au commissariat de police
à metz et a demandé à l'inspecteur
varlet si c'était une heure pour
interroger à mineure s'il ne pouvait pas
plutôt l'interrogé le lendemain matin
ça serait un peu plus convenable et
celui là vraiment énervé est pas content
la réaction de ma mère d'écouter mes
amis ici c'est encore moi qui commande
de toute manière vague fils il sera
interrogé le temps nécessaire afin qu'il
nous dise la vérité et ne sera pas
tranquille avant alors là écoutez voir
lorsque ça faisait des heures que je
disais la vérité
ouais lorsque l'on entend un inspecteur
ou dire à sa propre mère il ne sera
tranquille qu'à partir du moment où il y
aura la vérité ouais il ya une réaction
qui se fait si vous disais donc
l'inspecteur csi tous racontent tout tu
pourra rentrer chez toi
voilà c'était gillois voilà tu pourras
aller travailler demain matin
voilà sauf que problème c'est en cellule
que vous êtes entré et que vous
rentrerez chez vous seulement 15 ans un
quart autre raison de devaux aveux les
insultes les brimades les menaces de
mort dit vous dans votre livre de la
part de ce que vous appelez avec une
certaine ironie les gardiens de la paix
c'est à dire qu'ils vous ont forcé à
avouer le meurtre des deux enfants
je dirais qu'ils m'ont amené vous savez
on pourrait considérer ça à l entonnoir
ouais avec une sortie avait pas 36 mais
tant qu'il n'avait pas obtenu ce qu'il
souhaitait obtenir je rappe a été
tranquille ouais alors c'est vrai aussi
que de toute façon chez vous on avait
beaucoup de respect pour les
représentants de l'ordre donc ça vous
sembler naturel presque de de faire ce
que vous si c'était des adultes sans
représenter en plus autorité tout ce que
mes parents avaient un culte et le
respect des adultes formation de
l'autorité des personnes âgées donc
effectivement
ouais c'était compliqué un petit peu de
faire autrement oui alors autre raison
de vaud avait aussi deux hommes avaient
avoué avant vous il avait avoué
successivement être les meurtriers des
deux petits garçons avant de se
rétracter sens en plus de problèmes
ce qu'un mini drôle de région lab à
montigny-lès-metz quand il ya deux
enfants qui sont tués il ya trois
personnes innocentes qui avouent eux
étaient majeurs problème c'est que vous
on vous garde
[Musique]
alors contrairement à ce que vous pensez
effectivement les policiers se rendent
pas compte que vous mentez à ce moment
là si vous vous dites à un moment ils
vont comprendre que je raconte un
mensonge et je pense qu'ils ont dû noter
de ma sincérité à partir du moment où il
ya une enquête de voisinage est sans
aucune arrière pensée sans aucune
méchanceté sans l'intention de nuire la
justice lorsqu'on a demandé à ma mère si
on avait vu ou entendu quelque chose
j'étais à côté d'elle dans les escaliers
de la maison eh ben j'ai pas dis tout
simplement parce que j'avais vu entendu
ce soir là pourquoi j'avais pas eu
l'attention de leur mentir mais
uniquement parce que je ne pensais pas
un seul instant à ce moment là que ce
que j'avais pu voir ou entendre on
répète déterminant au capital pour la
suite des événements alors je parlais de
retrouver vos parents votre envie
irrépressible de rentrer à la maison a
quitté le commissariat et cette maison
était importante pour vous parce que
pour vous la cour de récréation c'était
un peu le cauchemar il faut dire des
choses patrick je tiens un petit peu le
souffre douleur de la classe gt elle
souffre douleur de la classe et pour
être tout à fait honnête
les deux seuls endroits où je me sentais
vraiment très bien il est évident
c'était dans ma famille chez mes parents
et sur mon lieu de travail
ouais alors on vous appelez le fil de
fer parce que vous êtes un
un peu grand rouquin le canard parce que
j'avais une mauvaise démarche rambo
parce que je suis tout le contraire
ouais enfin j'ai eu droit à tous les
styles de brimades et on a essayé par
tous les moyens de me faire craquer donc
les gars on se moque de vous parce que
vous avez un grand nez vous êtes grand
une drôle de démarche est un peu
maladroit un peu gauche peut-être un peu
gauche tu as fait et vous vous riposté
pas non je suis toujours parti du
principe quand ils en auront marre ils
arrêteront moi je suis pas partisan de
la violence et puis pour moi la violence
engendre la violence
donc en fait ils en auront marre ils
arrêteront tout simplement
et donc cette habitude que vous aviez
prise de parts riposté finalement dans
la cour de l'école
c'est la même attitude c'est tout ce que
je veux dire là c'est la même attitude
que vous avez en face d'un inspecteur de
police
tout à fait donc vous vous laissez faire
un peu un petit peu comme dans la croix
oui c'est tout simplement ça il ya on va
dire qu'il ya j'étais vraiment un enfant
qui sortait d'un un cocon familial
vraiment bien d'un construit bien
prenant j'étais tout le contraire
vraiment tout le contraire d'un enfant
des banlieues ou est-ce que si j'étais
vraiment sorti d'une banlieue croyez
m'en devant l'inspecteur marley moi je
vais retourner son bureau tu me fera pas
dire ce que j'ai pas envie mais bon
j'étais un peu trop doux pour que de
robien janvier mais voilà trop bien
élevé oui pis y avait donc comme on
disait chez vos parents qui sont des
gens modestes
il y avait un respect dites vous des des
grands de ce monde les gens qui sont
inaccessibles vous dit qu'il y avait une
espèce de complexe par rapport aux
classes sociales plus élevées vous vous
étiez un petit peu on peut dire dans les
jupes de votre maman j'ai dernière par
deux effectivement de la philatélie les
mac adam mc est un nom un monde
particulier en matière allemand que je
m'étais créé oui puisque j'étais un peu
rejetés par rapport aux autres
ouais il fallait bien un univers bien
sûr alors cet univers il est artificiel
est dans une espèce de cocon comme ça
qui alors tellement enfants à sa maman
que vous étiez vierge
à l'époque donc vous êtes entré en
prison vierge et vous l'êtes encore vous
dites je suis vierge car je refuse de
considérer le viol dont j'ai été victime
en prison comme une première fois ça n'a
rien à voir l'acte d'amour dit vous vous
réveillez connaître un jour tout à fait
je pense je comprends coup de foudre je
crois que l'amant c'est quelque chose
qui se mérite quelque chose qui se
respecte c'est quelque chose de beau et
vous savez quand on a pu patienter
quinze ans on posera santé ciment est
encore patienter un petit peu plus alors
avant ce violent qui est important parce
que ça ça démontre au delà de votre cas
personnel la façon dont les choses se
passent en prison s'est enchaîné
épouvantable quand on lit votre bouquin
avant ce viol donc qu'il ya eu toujours
comme l'humiliation dans la cour de
récréation
il ya eu des problèmes avec les
codétenus parce que effectivement je dis
pas faut se mettre à leur place mais
enfin pour eux vous êtes quand même un
meurtrier d'enfants
on est tout à fait vous avez le nôtre
d'enfants c'est parce qu'il faut savoir
que dans une prison il ya une hiérarchie
sociale
et oui le meurtre d'enfants c'est ce qui
a le plus bas c'est ça de plus
détestable
de plus répréhensibles au sein même des
murs donc non seulement et je devais
affronter la justice
je devais affronter le monde pénal mais
également les codes et les coûts des
tenues qui se privait pas de vous
frapper alors vous dites avec un torchon
mouillé ou alors avec une chaussette
dans laquelle il mettait une savonnette
et en général les gens qui sont en
prison pour des délits vraiment
crapuleux et bien il ne supporte pas
leur propre délit alors pour justement
essayer entre guillemets de le supporter
eh bien ils essaient de trouver pire que
et puis justement de se venger pour
oublier leurs propres problèmes vous dit
patrick dils avoir eu honte de votre
manque de courage face à ces corrections
ben oui parce que j'aurais aimé avoir la
force courage d'avancer le courage de
riposter le courage de dire stop
maintenant ça suffit il faut réagir
mais là encore c'est dû à une éducation
c'est dû à mon caractère
on change pas le caractère d'une
personne en un claquement de doigts
excusez moi vous aviez pas trouvé un ami
sur lequel vous appuyez parce qu'il ya
aussi une certaine solidarité qui peut
s'installer parfois dans la prison
quelqu'un qui est plus sûr plus
attentifs qui peut comprendre lorsque
vous y avez parlé tout de notre problème
puisque est-ce que vous est confiée en
prison en disant je suis innocent parce
que vous l'avez clamé en effet que ça
m'a montré que j'ai pu une fois
rencontré des gens qui ont été
extrêmement serviable vraiment gentil
des gens qui ont voulu se substituer au
rôle de père et dire maintenant tu
laisses tu laisses tranquille le monde
ce qu'il a fait c'est pas à toi d'en
juger
le temps qui sera avec moi tu leur as 4
a pas tu toucheras pas sinon c'est
maintenant à faire heureusement elle a
eu des gens pas de s'assurer là je leur
tire mon chapeau parce qu'il y en a
certains qui sont aujourd'hui en prison
d'autres qui sont sortis parce qu'il
faut savoir que la prison c'est un petit
peu comme une balance roberval vous avez
les très mauvais moment là je peux en
parler en connaissance de cause mais
heureusement pour moi et puis pour mes
proches qui ont toujours cru en moi
il ya eu des moments extraordinaires et
c c'est un moment extraordinaire pardon
qui ont permis de garder les deux pôles
la balance hommage à peu près ajusté qui
veut dire que quand vous êtes victime de
de brimades ou de correction de la part
de vos codétenus
les matons sont jamais là ils sont
jamais là quand il faut
vous savez je pense que ça peut comme la
police on a besoin d'elle elle n'est pas
là qui quand on n'a pas besoin d'aller
en revanche les matons ils sont toujours
là pour mater 1
dans les douches quand vous prenez votre
douche a toujours un qui se met au
milieu comme ça qui regarde un peu ce
qui se passe
il n'y a pas cru au niveau des douches
savez l'oeil tant on dit que c'est pour
la sécurité du détenu mais aussi c'est
un bon moyen pour le voyeurisme
mouais on traite très souvent le détenu
d'être pervers
avant de dire que c'est un homosexuel
mais vous savez il s'en passe de belles
aux côtés de l'oeil
les fouilles aussi vous parler des fous
ils sont traités les uns pour faire des
fouilles oui les fous sont vraiment
particulière au niveau les parloirs
heureusement elles ont évolué ces
dernières années
mais
en dix ans à toul j'ai eu à faire à
certains surveillants
vous connaissez aucun problème
connaissant en parcourant et vasili long
parloir passe un bon moment et pierre
d'autres bons la fouille à corps normal
puis d'autres moi j'ai des yeux pour
regarder les yeux on voyait bien là où
ils s'arrêtaient donc avec une lourde
insistance
c'est terrible parce qu'on se sent sans
milliers là tu attends quoi là qu'est ce
que tu veux et là encore on peut rien
dire parce que eux ils ont une forme et
n'ont hélas pas c'était bien fiancé
c'est là on aime ça c'est le truc c'est
humain terrifiant d'abord quand ils se
remettre en question n'est toujours bien
de se justifier toujours afin
d'expliquer alors qu'on dit oui la
conasysed vous jugera ou la
correctionnel jugera
non c'est continuellement c'est pas un
jour et c'est là qui à cette date assez
importante finalement on va le voir mais
très très dramatique pour vous c'est le
viol quoi c'est à dire que finalement
votre premier contact sexuel dans votre
vie ça a été ce violent et c'est à
partir de là que vous décidez de réagir
de relever la tête et de plus rien
accepté je dirais que c'est la goutte
qui a fait déborder le vase
mais il ya d'autres choses bien avant
c'est à dire que au départ quand je suis
en prison
par rapport par rapport à toutes les
brimades que j'avais pu subir à l'école
et puis bien d'ailleurs
je suis tombé avec un codétenu
kim à une fois vu en sortant de la
douche dans la cellule en train de me
regarder le visage dans le miroir et
puis en train de ne pas être satisfait
de mon propre visage la direccte du
parti karl de déconner là parce que tu
arrêtes de me prendre la tête ça va pas
je suis les ruchers rien fait dit non
mais ça fait au moins 10 minutes devant
le miroir là tu as des boutons à des
boutons parce que tu veux te
they play où tu te plaît pas maintenant
je me plaît pas je m'aime pas et puis
alors la mise du ces pour pouvoir aimer
les autres il faut d'abord que tu
puisses tu n es toi-même et je serai pas
très bien saisir ce qu'ils voulaient me
faire comprendre cette personne faisait
de la peinture
et puis il m'a mis dans la salle de
peinture m'a dit vous de voir qu'est ce
que tu vois sur ce tableau
ben écoute moi je vois ça ça et puis ça
et tu vois là moi je regarde la même
toile que toi eh ben je vois pas du tout
la même chose que toi
l'être humain c'est un peu comme une
toile toi tu va me plaire
la personne qui sera à côté de moi tu ne
lui plaira pas alors à partir du moment
où tu as pris conscience de ça va tu as
fait un grand pas et là ça a été le
premier déclic il a bien sûr il y en a
eu il y en a eu beaucoup
alors donc le viol vous raconter
l'histoire à un scénario classique
et après avoir fait son truc quoi le mec
vous laisse là un truc plan ou terminés
de la cellule et puis à quatre pattes et
quatre pattes et puis vraiment humiliée
honteux
j'étais là je pouvais pas réagir j'étais
j'avais les larmes aux yeux gt gt
soulier gt gt meurtri dans sa chair
et croyez moi
très honnêtement si on n'avait pas forcé
pour l'assise de lyon n'en parle et je
n'en aurai jamais parlé si je dis tout
ça concrètement dans le livre c'est pour
que ça soit dit une fois pour toutes
qu'on comprenne bien qu'en prison mais
se passe pas toujours des choses pas
catholiques quelque chose qui pourrait
être évité et que malheureusement les
gens ferment les yeux ça c'est honteux
et inadmissible et que ce qui est arrivé
à moi
il faut plus que ça arrive à un autre
parce que vous savez quand une femme se
fait violer elle a honte elle veut pas
en parler
elle se sent salle alors imaginez un
seul instant quand il a eu vent de cette
chose abominable arrive à un homme mais
c'est le ciel qui tombe sur la tête
c'est je sais encore aujourd'hui alors
que ça fait plus de dix ans ça m'est
arrivé c'était comme si c'était hier je
peux pas cessé
écoutez c'est terrible c'est terrible et
il en restera des traces
je pense à vie parce que ça fait mal ou
non quelque chose alors je rapprocher
cette cette scène que vous décrivez dans
votre bouquin d'une phrase de vous vous
dites je vais devenir un homme digne qui
marchent la tête haute qui tient la main
de ses enfants dans la rue et qui sourit
à sa femme on voit très bien
l'opposition des deux images
voilà après c'est la libération première
sensation de liberté et ses traits à
quoi ça tient
c'est le moelleux des coussins d'une
voiture 1 oui c'est le je me suis
effondrée dans le fauteuil pas
l'habitude d'être assis dans un canapé
les choses très simples les étoiles le
vent les odeurs et vous avez au bord de
l'eau je peux regarder le couler oui
j'ai l'impression que les gens ne savent
plus apprécié la juste valeur de cette
liberté qui est tellement belle qui est
magique et ça il peut pleuvoir peu neigé
peu venté peut arriver n'importe quoi
moi je suis toujours content vous
écouter les gens lui à faire beau ils
vont se plaindre il va pleuvoir
ils vont se plaindre qu'elle les impôts
à payer ils vont se plaindre mais quand
est ce qu'ils seront heureux pour être
heureux je pense qu'il faut qu'il soit
pleinement satisfait et puis surtout est
ce qui est important c'est à dire et je
pense que c'est que moi malheureusement
j'étais dans une véritable prison il y
avait de vrais murs y avait de vrais
barreau de vraies clés devraient bruit
de vraies violences
mais contrairement à tout ça je pense
qu'il ya moins de 50% de la population
qui se met elle-même dans une prison
virtuelle et là ça c'est grave c'est
très très grave parce que elles sont
contre elle se contrôle plus elles mêmes
elles sont elles sont bouffés par la vie
est là c'est dramatique c'est dramatique
la ville est tellement belle comment
vous avez eu le courage de tenir tout
c'est tout ce qui vous est arrivé ça
vous êtes croyants
des choses profondes en vous en faites
vous savez la religion c'est quelque
chose qui m'a qui m'a détruit en prison
au niveau de la cour d'assises parce que
ça a été très très mal interprété ou
d'une phrase lorsque je on me demande si
je suis croyant je dis oui
avez vous quelque chose à vous faire
pardonner je dis oui en pensant à tous
les mentions que j'avais pu dire et sur
le procès-verbal cette étape est le
meneur
donc ça c'est ça vous l'aï dit on
profite je sais même pas maintenues et
d'hermine et je voudrais simplement
effectivement j'ai une certaine croyance
je suis convaincu qu'il existe quelque
chose qu'il ya une force divine mais
tout simplement si je suis aujourd'hui
ici devant vous c'est avant tout par
rapport à moi-même
par rapport à ma propre innocence par
rapport à mes parents par rapport à mon
frère alain par rapport à mes avocats
par rapport à mai mais comité de soutien
par rapport à tous ceux qui ont cru en
moi et qui aujourd'hui même profondément
et c'est pour eux je me suis battu c'est
évidemment pour moi la voix parce que je
l'étais j'étais innocent mais eux m'ont
donné cette énergie également de me
battre une mère extraordinaire c'est un
roc c'est extra c'était pascal a
complètement changé à l'heure actuelle
elle est devenue elle a fondu elle venue
contre coup maintenant rouler contre un
contrecoup moi pas c'est que votre mère
a dit simon fille c'était était coupable
j'aurai emmenez moi même à la police et
après je me serais suicidé jeté un froid
qu'on l'a 6 on a bien vu que c'était
quelque chose qui n'était pas préparé
c'était une triste réalité
alors voilà le grand moment aussi donc à
cette première sensation de liberté donc
les coussins de la voiture ça a l'air de
rien mais bon et puis ensuite vous
retournez dans votre maison maison
familiale à montigny-lès-metz et là vous
retrouvez vous retrouver les timbres
vous retrouvez les puzzles vous
retrouvez les les maquettes je
retrouvais tout ce que j'avais laissé
que 16 ans après l'audience d'encre l
odeur de colle 16 ans après vous
retrouver tous c'est on va dire que les
premières réactions
on aurait pu éventuellement me comparer
un petit chiot qui va courir dans toutes
les pièces
tellement content de retrouver quelque
chose qu'il a connus ou quelque chose de
nouveau qui est très important pour lui
bon ça peut faire sourire mais je sens
que s'ils en attendent et c'est si bien
représentatif parce que ça m'a tellement
manqué j'ai tellement rêver comme à
cette liberté
vous savez je dirais que tout au long de
ce drame qui a duré 15 ans il ya eu une
première victoire
c'est quand la cour de cassation a pris
la grande décision de casser la décision
de la cour d'assises de la moselle en 89
et de me donner une nouvelle chance pour
une prochaine cour d'assises ça c'est la
première victoire la seconde victoire
est la plus belle pour tous ceux qui ont
cru en moi c'était bien évidemment
l'acquittement et au troisième procès je
dire honnêtement
en ce qui me concerne ça a été une
victoire certes mais j'ai pas souhaité
jouer au plafond j'ai pas été aussi
heureux que tous ceux qui ont cru en moi
l'ont été pour moi tout simplement parce
que si vous voulez je récupérer ce qu'on
m'avait volé quinze ans plus tôt et
qu'on me rendais c'était pour moi
légitime c'était juste été normal donc
j'avais pas sauter au plafond
par contre la troisième et la plus belle
des victoires c'est quand je serai
qu'est ce qui s'est passé
sur ce talus le 28 septembre 1986 et
pourquoi on a enlevé la vie à ses deux
petites victimes qui ne souhaitait
qu'une chose vivre grandir et réussir
comme moi leur vie meilleure
effectivement quand vous retournez à
montigny-lès-metz
vous allez sur ce tas lui dire qu'on
vous dit mais enfin tu vas pas aller là
du mec bourré j'irai pas j'ai rien j'ai
rien à me reprocher je peux aller voir
l'endroit où l'arrivée 10 lots c'est
comme l'art pont-à-mousson c'est comme
dans l'avenue des champs-elysées c'est
une rue comme les autres qui les a tués
ces moments là je peux pas vous répondre
je n'en sais rien francis heaulme à je
ne permettrai jamais de dire francis
haut mais l'auteur des faits pour la
bonne et simple raison ayant passé 15
ans en prison et ayant été innocent de
ce drame de ce drame terrible est atroce
je ne peux pas me permettre d'accuser
quelqu'un ça serait trop dramatique
maintenant à la justice de faire son
travail et surtout j'espère que cette
justice ne mettra pas 15 ans pour
trouver la vérité parce que si moi je
veux savoir ce qui s'est passé
j'estime que les parents méritent encore
plus que moi de savoir la vérité afin
qu'il puisse enfin faire le deuil de
leurs deux enfants et espérer survivre
parce qu'on ne vit pas un dragon patrick
dit je ne sais pas si vous disiez je
sais pas si je suis croyant en tous les
cas vous êtes chrétien je peux vous le
dire parce que vous vous pardonner aux
parents des deux petites victimes qui
continue à dire que c'est vous le
coupable
et vous vous avez cette charité
chrétienne de dire bah finalement je
comprends qu'ils pensent ça je leur en
veux pas
on sait pas de leur faute ils ont
souffert et c'est beau parce qu'il
continue à vous accusez 14 ans qu'il
vous haïssez aujourd'hui on leur dit de
changer de coupables c'est difficile de
quelle façon la justice contre réparer
son erreur à votre endroit côté là je
suis obligé de sourire mais avec à
souhait très très journée très très très
dur parce que la justice pourra faire ce
qu'elle veut à mon égard qu'elle me
donne tout l'or du monde
hopla me donne le franc symbolique
honnêtement les 15 ans qui sont écoulés
la et savez c'est comme une cigarette
ces partis en fumée c'est du consumer il
n'y a plus rien qui le rendra ses 15 mai
c'est à dire pardon mais je peux dire à
yvan des gens qui ont été victimes
d'erreurs judiciaires comme patrick dils
reçoivent 400 mille francs 300 mille
francs 500 mille francs 150 mille francs
à dire c'est pas des sommes qu'ils
valent 15 ans de la vie de quelqu'un de
toute façon y'a aucune somme qu'il vaut
enfin tous les cas ce sont de très
petites sommes là ce soir là vous êtes
bien ça va extrêmement heureux de vivre
de pouvoir faire partager mon expérience
malheureusement la triste expérience de
la vie et puis comme je les ai également
moi j'ai pu le confier
non là c'est encore un peu tôt parce que
ça fait à peine six mois je suis devenu
un homme libre mais
et
aussi on est que vous je dirais c'est
que
quand les problèmes matériels seront
réglés et ben jeu qu'on veut faire du
social je vais pas me mettre à profit
encore une fois ça tu étais triste
expérience dans les écoles primaires
pour faire prendre conscience aux
enfants que la liberté c'est quelque
chose de magique qui font prendre soin
qu'il faut faire très attention et un
côté beaucoup plus je dirais plus
plus fort cette année dans les écoles de
magistrature les écoles de police
et puis leur faire comprendre que leurs
décisions qui sont amenés à prendre plus
tard elles sont très lourds de
conséquences et qu'il fasse très
attention avant de se prononcer sur
quelqu'un ou sur quelque chose alors
vous vivez comment votre notoriété parce
que là c'est un peu comme si vous
sortiez du loft l'a déjà le mollah ne me
plaît pas du tout 1 à la notoriété
j'ai souvent entendu il ya deux mois la
star
là la vedette je suis une star mise une
bonnette je suis une victime du système
judiciaire
ouais je pense que je le dis très bien
dans le livre il y en a qui vont qu'il
mette toute une vie pour devenir célèbre
moi je vais mettre le restant de mes
jours pour retomber dans l'anonymat
j'aspire pas grand chose je demande pas
à décrocher la lune a fondé un foyer à
réussir à la vie professionnelle
avoir un commerce puisque c'est là mon
rêve depuis l'âge de 9 ans
les ferrari sont resteront une
pâtisserie jeu ça va encore mais dans le
domaine de la bouche et puis être
heureux vivre vivre simplement avant un
cercle d'amis
c'est peu en fin de compte donc comme
n'importe qui je pense que j'y ai droit
au début vous êtes venu à paris
travailler et puis ça vous à stresser un
oui j'ai eu la chance de tomber sur des
patrons vraiment excellent charmant qui
ont fait comme une approche remarquable
à mon égard et puis à l'égard de mon
frère qu'est ce qui m'a accompagné un
personnel
remarquable également et
mais si je suis parti c'est pas parce
que l'emploi me convenait pas c'est pas
parce que j'avais des difficultés avec
le patron c'est pas parce que j'avais
des difficultés à m'intégrer au niveau
la société de la société mais simplement
parce que je ne pouvais pas vivre à
paris j'étais en train de tomber malade
pour vous comprenez bien ce que je
pouvais ressentir à ce moment là c'est
comme quand vous sortez de là manège
vraiment qui vous donne le tournis et
non c'était trop dur pour moi et
on l'a très vite compris qu'il fallait
me faire partir de là parce que sinon
j'aurais pu faire du mal mais pas du mal
à autrui peuvent faire du mal à moi même
et puis peut-être
en arriver à des situations dramatiques
alors avant de se quitter
patrick dils je vais lire un mail de
gabriel tessier que j'ai reçu puisque
donc maintenant les téléspectateurs
peuvent envoyer des mails en fonction
des invités qui sont sur le plateau
c'est une dame de colmar elle m'écrit ce
n'est pas une question c'est juste un
mot pardon pardon parce que c'est au nom
du peuple français que vous avez été
condamné
patrick dils
je veux juste rentrer chez moi
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
le in a l'habitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux